a pocos días de cumplirse cinco meses el
presidente guillermo lazo en el poder
ecuador vive un clima de tensión
política y se convocan movilizaciones en
el país a favor y en contra el ejecutivo
la presidencia de la república y la
asamblea nacional mantienen desacuerdos
el primer mandatario advirtió que
disolverá el parlamento si éste continúe
en su constante bloqueo afirmó guillermo
lasso mientras que la asamblea cuestionó
que el gobierno no establecido proceso
de diálogo con la legislatura el
presidente expreso inclusive que ya
tiene listo el decreto y disolución de
la asamblea y convocar a nuevas
elecciones una atribución constitucional
que mantiene a presidente de la
república mientras sus adherentes son
convocados al palacio de gobierno para
expresar así su solidaridad con éste
no podemos permitir que ese triunvirato
es el triunvirato de conspiradores
pretendan echar abajo una conquista del
pueblo con la elección del presidente
lazo las organizaciones sociales
aseguran que la presidencia de la
república dialoga pero no ofrece
soluciones a las necesidades de la
ciudadanía los trabajadores también
salen a marchar para rechazar el
principal proyecto de ley del ejecutivo
un mega proyecto de ley que incluye
reformas tributarias laborales y de
inversión entre otras que no fue
calificada por el parlamento y presentan
una nueva propuesta de ley del código
del trabajo en medio de un estado de
excepción para decirle al gobierno de
guillermo lasso que no estamos de
acuerdo con sus reformas antiobreras con
la reforma tributaria que pretende
perdonar a los grandes evasores una gran
marcha nacional agrupa a las
organizaciones sociales el 26 de octubre
en el color en medio de un estado de
excepción que no limita las protestas
pero cuestionado para contenerlas